We controlled for the time at which participants took the pill, the place at
which they slept, because they all slept in the sleep lab, and what the pill
looks like? It looks the same for both the active and the placebo. We did not
however control for gender and age. We can, however, minimize the impact of
these variables on the results. Let me elaborate on this a little bit. Let's say
that only females were assigned to the active pill. And only males were assigned
to the inactive pill. Then, if people who took the active pill slept better. We
wouldn't know if it was due to the medication in the pill or maybe women just
sleep better than men. In this particular experiment, we are not controlling for
these demographic variables, but we can minimize their impact on our results
through random assignment.